[Music]  Bella Hadid is filling sexy in the  bathroom the model shared a series of  sultry videos on her instant story on  Tuesday posing in the mirror rocking MP  underwear twenty-one-year-old looked  radiant going makeup free while showing  off her toned tummy in a black tank top  I'm just really happy well that bathroom  moment was seemingly one of Bella's few  seconds of downtime her modeling career  is keeping her very busy  she jetted off to Korea for work and of  course she first had to fuel up on  coffee to make it through a full day on  set staying on set till 9:00 p.m. it's  always hard but I guess it's worth it  and you know now it's cool I guess I'm  doing something right